عمركم شفتوا ناس بتحتفل بخساره منتخببها
الايرانيون عملوها
ومطالبات باقالات في وزاره الثقافه في
الاردن والسبب روايه متهمه بالاباحيه
والبذاءه والحقائب الفاخره سوق استثمار في
صعود اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه من اخبار كاس العالم والمباراه
المنتظره خلال ساعات للمنتخب السعودي مع
منتخب المكسيك والحاسمه في التاهل لدور ال
16 منتخبنا من بدايه المونديال ومقدم اداء
مشرف والان الحماس على اشده والتمنيات
المستحق للدور 16 ان شاء الله وحاليا وانا
بكلمكم جماهير المنتخب السعودي في الدوحه
عاملين مسيره باتجاه الاستاذ لدعم المنتخب
وهينقلنا المشهد زميلنا من الدوحه مراسل
العربيه النايف الثقيل اهلا فيك معنا نايف
احكي لي ايش اللي صاير عندك الحماس اكيد
يعني على اشده
اهلا وسهلا طبعا نحن الان نقف في منطقه
التجمع الجماهير السعوديه تقريبا يعني
خلال دقائق او بدات تصل الحافلات تنقل
جماهير تقريبا ست اكثر من 6000 مشجعها
هؤلاء يعني رابطه رسميه للمنتخب السعودي
بخلاف الجماهير التي اجتمعت الان تشاهدين
الخلفي الجماهير السعوديه عندما يكتمل
العدد ينتقلون على الاقدام لمده نصف ساعه
الى الملعب خليني اخذ توقعات الجماهير ان
شاء الله تاهو للسعوديه واحد صفر ان شاء
الله يعطيك سالم تاهل باذن الله سعودي
اثنين واحد سالم باذن
الجمهور
اغلب الجموع
ههه
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
هيكون روعه شكلك في اللايفات يا نايف
يقول خدمه يقول خدمه خمس نجوم
والله ما خدمك ابدا احنا نقدم نقدم
الجمهور لان اللعيبه ما قصروا صراحه بدايه
البطوله
واش تتوقع
طبعا الرجال جامعه
[تصفيق]
ههه
ندعسهم دعس دعس يلا يا شباب
هذول المكسيكي
تيتي تيتي هذول
المكسيكي
ان شاء الله
والملعب
يعني تقريبا
لجميع ان شاء الله وفي تفاؤل في اشكال
والالوان زي ما تقبل الناس كلهم خضر كل
الناس خضر ما فيهم كيفك اليوم يوم اخضر
باذن الله باذن الواحد الاحد
طبعا سوا الجمهور السعودي من افضل
الجماهير واكثرها في همم في الدوحه
وتلقاهم في كل مكان ومتفاعلين في كل مكان
يعني بكل حياديه يعني احنا بنتكلم انا
وانت كمان يا نايف بس خليني اقول لك نايف
ههه
لون لك وجهك بس يضبط لك الموضوع
اوكي لانه الامور تمام
بنضبط اولا يلا ان شاء الله الامور تمام
شكرا لك
العربيه نايف الثقيل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تاهل امس منتخب امريكا لدور 16 في كاس
العالم بعد فوزوا على ايران بهدف لا شيء
مباراه ومواجهه كانت منتظره وتكلمنا عنها
باستفاضه يعني امريكا وايران واقفين في
وجه بعض في الحقيقه وفي السياسه فلما
يلعبوا مع بعض اكيد هذا حدث مو بس رياضي
والفوز في عندك ثانيين مو بس رياضي كمان
الامريكيين اللي يعني كره القدم مو من
اشهر اللعب عندهم طبيعي انبسط هو احتفلوا
كمان بالفوز لكن لما تشوف ايرانيين في
الشوارع بيحتفلوا بخساره منتخب بلادهم هذا
اللي شيء مو طبيعي ابدا بصراحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الايرانيين المحترفلين معتبرين انه
المنتخب هو منتخب النظام اللي هما ضده
ونفسهم يخلصوا منه واللي معيشهم في ظروف
يعني يطول الحديث عنها والي كمان طالعه
مظاهرات ضده ضد ممارساته في البلد وما
بتهدئ هذه المظاهرات من سبتمبر المظاهرات
هذه على فكره كثير من اللاعبين نفسهم
بيدعموها بس يعني ما باليد حيله يعني
الجماعه لما غنوا النشيد الوطني في اول
مباراه اتهددوا وصاروا يغنوا من بعدها بس
للعلم مو اول مره ايران بتهدد رياضيين
عندها ولا شكلها طبعا هتكون اخر مره اصلا
يعني هذه طبيعتهم يعني على الناحيه
الثانيه في امريكا كان في احتياج يعني
كروي ومعنوي لهذا الفوز على منتخب ايران
وفي الوقت نفسه كانت بتبحث عن الانتقام
لخسارتها في مونديال 98 امام منتخب ايراني
ومن اكثر المقاطع مشاهده وتداول هو مقطع
ابلاغ بايظن بيفوز منتخب بلاده واحتفاله
[موسيقى]
والنعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جديد
الى الاردن جديده
بيان مدح في الروائي والتاريخ وشرح فكره
الروايه واكد انه الوزاره سحبتها فقط
مراعاه للسياق الاجتماعي والثقافي وانها
ما بتمارس دور الوصايه على القراء وانهم
مقدرين روح النقد والحوار اللي جرحوا
الروايه لكن الجدل والغضب بعد هذا البيان
ما هدي وكثر ما عجبتهم لغه البيان اللي
صحيح انه اعلن يعني فيها او اعلن فيها سحب
الروايه لكن ما اذان الروايه ومن الاصوات
الناقده كانت من جوه البرلمان اللي الازمه
وصلت تحت قبه
في ظل روايه مست كل اسره اردنيه تحت عنوان
مكتبه الاسره الاردنيه اساءت للاسره
الاردنيه بل واساءت للقيم
الاخلاقيه في الدوله الاردنيه وكان رد
الوزاره باعتبار انا اعتبره اوقح من الذنب
الذي ارتكبه في ماريه الدوله هناك من يسعى
لهدم قيم واعراف والاسس التي بنيت عليها
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه وبيان الوزاره
سعاده الرئيس والزملاء الكرام كان مع
الروايه ظلمات بعضها فوق بعض ويعبر عن
نهجري سمج ومنحرف يصادم الدين والاخلاق
وكل قيم المجتمع انا اطلب من ساعات الرئيس
كل الموظفين المسؤولين عن نشر هذه الروايه
ان يتم محاسبتهم واقانتهم من عملهم وان لا
نكتفي بتشكيل اللسان يعني انا بس بحب احكي
انه هذا عذر اقبح من ذنب اللي همم ما جاء
في وزاره الثقافه وانا باعتقادي لازم
اليوم فعليا يتوقف عن العمل كل من له
علاقه بهذه باقترح تكلف لجنه التوجيهي
الوطني بمتابعه هذا الموضوع بعد ما تاخذ
كل قطرها من انتخاب الرئيس
اغلبيه واضحه
الغضب والانتقادات هي الصوت اعلى صحيح لكن
لازم نقول انه مو الوحيد بسبب الانتقاد
كمان مو واحد يعني في ناس من تقده فكره
الروايه ومضمونها من الاساس ورفضه انها
تنشر اصلا وبطالب بمحاسبه المسؤولين في
وزاره الثقافه وحتى في منهم بيطالبوا
باقاله الوزيره نفسها لكن في ناس ثانيه مع
حريه الكتابه والتعبير بس اعتراض انه
مضمون الروايه لمرحله عمريه معينه وابدا
ما ينفع تكون في مكتبه الاسره او في
متناول جميع افرادها من كل المراحل
العمريه
[موسيقى]
ايه الازمه الاقتصاديه اللي بيعيشها
العالم موضوع ما بيخفى على احد ومعها طبعا
تضخم وغلاء معي شيء وبزنس بتعاني وغيره
لكن في ظروف زي هذه في ناس برده بتعرف
تلاقي مجلات تستثمر فيها وتجني ارباح
ومجالات الاستثمار يعني كثير جدا منها
التقليدي اللي نعرفه منها الجديد همم مثلا
العملات الرقميه الانفتي وغيرها
في استثماري مو تقليدي وهو بصراحه مو جديد
لكن في تقارير اقتصاديه بتتكلم عن
انتعاشوا الفتره الماضيه وهو الاستثمار
فيه الشنط شنط اليد الي بتنشال عادي
فالشنط اللي من الماركات الفاخره والشهيره
هي الان فرصه للاستثمار واكثر جسمين
بيعملوا من وراها فلوس خلينا نكون متفقين
انه يعني هذا استثمار ما راح يخلي صاحبه
او صاحبته مليونير لكنها ببساطه سلعه
عائدها الاستثماري عالي يعني ممكن تشتريها
وبعد كم سنه تبيعها باضعف سعرها وتكسب
نسبه احيانا تتجاوز 100% طيب الاسباب
كثيره منها انه اسعار الشنط نفسها مع
الغلاء بتغلى وانه في كثير من هذا الشنط
بس حول قطع نادره او مميزه بيسال الناس
انهم يحصلوا عليها فيصير الواحد او يعني
انه الوحده انه يشتروا شنطه اليوم بكم الف
او كم 10,000 او غيره يعني ويركنها فتره
ويرجع يبيعها بعد كم سنه لما سعرها والطلب
عليها يعني اه طبعا العائد بيكون اعلى
بكثير لما الشنط ما بتكون استخدمت ابدا
يعني بتنباع جديده في همم طبعا اصلا في
العالم سوق شنط فاخره مستعمله وناس كثير
بتستعمل وترجع تبيعه وحتى هذول قلت لو
قطعه مميزه فممكن ينباعوا باكثر من السعر
اللي انشره فيه وهذا الشيء بحسب الدراسه
الاخيره خلي الاستثمار في الشنط يتفوق على
الاستثمار في مجالات ثانيه بنفس الطريقه
مثل السياره وفي دراسه لشركه
انه اللي حاصل هذا راح يعلق قيمه سوق
الشنط الفاخر العالمي من 72 مليار دولار
وهي قيمه المقدره هذه السنه عشان يصلي 100
مليار دولار في 20/07 27
هذا الموضوع مفضل جدا للنقاش عندي مع
زميلتنا في قسم الاقتصاد فاطمه الزهراء
كيف حالك يا فاطمه
كثير من الناس اللي يعني حوالينا او
بنعرفهم مهو الستات بشكل عام او حتى
الرجال الان صاروا من حملت الحقائب ايضا
خلينا نقول يعني طيب صحيح هذا الكلام
طيب خلينا نبدا من شو معناتها استثمار
هل هي فئه طبقه تعتمد على راتب شهري وما
عندها داخل اضافي لازم نحدد هذا الموضوع
فاحنا التقارير اللي عم تصدره وبتتحدث انه
لربما بعد القطع ااه شنط من براندات معينه
لها كثير من الاكس او شروط اولا لما يكون
شخص
او وده دخل معين سنوي ايش هي الاولويات في
الاستتبار هل الاولويات انه نستثمر في
براند في ماركات شنط لا اكيد لانه لما
بنحط البرتفوليوم لا اداره الثروات لازم
يكون عندك نسبه معينه من الاستثمار في
الاسهم حصص في شركات مدرجه فوق ال 20%
لازم يكون عندك حساس في عقار استت مرات في
العقار هذه الاولويه
للاكشنري او الحاجات همم
ازازه سميه والكلام ده فبيكون يوم متنوع
الناس اللي زيي عندهم حساب في البنك
5% لازم يكون بالكوليكتبلز هم تحت مظله
الكوليكتبلز الاشياء
مثلا مثلا
وضعها في المتناول البيع خلال حقبه سعرها
هل هو استثمار لانه لو فتحت مثلا
كبير للسوق الثانويه للاشياء المستخدمها
مثلا شنطه شانيل سعرها 3000 استرليني او
ثلاث الاف يورو هي بالمحل بتعمل 7000 8000
يورو وبالتالي الجديد عليه طلب هذا شو خلق
خلق سوق ما بين السكن هان والسوق اللي
موجود بالمحل اللي هو بيسوي دروي سيلر
ماركت اللي هو زي الكونسيرج او مثل
الكونسيرج بيجيب لك الشنطه وبيعطيك بتدفعي
عليها زياده هنا على السعر لو انا كشخص
عاوزه اشتغل ويصير عندي راتب او دخل همم
بيروحوا كان موظفين بيلفوا على كل المحلات
بيشتروا الشنط بتصير غير متوفره في المحل
وبالتالي السعر اللي هم عاوزيين ياخذوا
عليه غير متوفره
الدخل من اللي دفعته فيها لكن دخل عادي ما
حدا حقق انه مثلا اذا مثلا هذه الشنط
توقفت تماما ايوه وحتى لو كانت عندك
مستعمله وصار عليها طلبنا القصه قصه عرض
طلب والان مواقع التواصل اجتماعي صاروا
يحددوا هذا الموضوع بشكل كبير وصر
وبيدفعوا الطلب اكثر مقابل اللي صار كذلك
هالسنتين صار خلال كورونا توقفت سلاسل
الامداد صار في الشح للمواد الاساسيه اوكي
الجلد وغيرها او بالتالي صار العرض
الانتاج اقل من الطلب مين اللي زادوا
الطلب الانفلونزا المؤثرين همم وضع هذه
المقتنيات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لرفع عدد المتابعين وبالتالي صار في طلب
غير مباشر على هذه المنتجات وبالتالي في
ارتفاع غير مبرر لهذه المنتجات كمان
ارتفاع غير مبرر وايضا كيو صغير
انت اي قطعه بتتحدث عنها تعطيني عذر اني
اقدر اقول للناس انه والله انا بشتري هذا
الشيء استثمار بس هذا عذر الكل بيستخدمه
كمراه امام ولي امرها سواء ابوها او زوجها
او غيره انه لكي تبرد استثمار يعني
استثمار في ادوات مختلفه كثير كمان
همم الاستثمار في هذه
الفئه من المنتجات ليست اولويه لاي شخص
يريد ان يكون عنده استقلاليا ماليه لازم
يكون عندك نسبه في العقار نسبه اسهم مدرجه
نسب شركات خاصه
ههه مدتنا عذر طيب كانت معنا في استديو
زميلتنا فاطمه الضيوي مشاهدينا انا اعيد
القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في الخميس الونيس
في امان الله
[موسيقى]